[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight we don't do a lot of weather
segments on the show but we couldn't
help but notice this phenomenon called a
polar vortex that's descended on the
Midwestern United States this week
temperatures dropped to lows that didn't
even seem real parts of the state of
Illinois fell to 38 degrees below zero
this morning that's a new state record
in Thief River Falls Minnesota the
temperature approached 80 below well
cold like that will turn hot coffee to
ice crystals before it hits the ground
stay outside for any length of time and
you will die and a number of people did
in that region they were found froze to
death in the last few days I mean you're
all just and this is the good news say
it will warm up soon climate change will
continue as it always has spring will
come but this is a good reminder of
something energy matters it keeps us
alive what would happen if you didn't
have energy what's something we maybe
need to consider very soon because
there's something called the green New
Deal
what is that it's not clear take a look
now at a description by the chief
proponent of the green New Deal watch
you're talking about zero carbon
emissions no use of fossil fuels within
12 years that is the goal
it's ambitious yeah I was that posture
he talked about everybody happening to
drive an electric cart it's going to
require a lot of rapid change that we
don't even conceive as possible right
now
so no fossil fuels within 12 years
there's a lot we don't know about this
plan but that would definitely be the
headline they've spelled it up very
clearly now before we can assess whether
getting to that point no fossil fuels in
12 years is even possible it is as the
congresswoman just said an ambitious
goal let's consider what it would mean
for the United States no fossil fuels
would mean no coal no oil no ad natural
gas and that would mean no cars and no
airplanes it would mean shutting down
the single most vibrant part of the
entire US economy which is the energy
sector it would mean putting at least
six million
out of work immediately as of today
America is the largest oil producer in
the world the country exports more
natural gas in any other place more than
90 percent of all of our energy comes
from fossil fuels and nuclear power then
we'd have to figure out a way to replace
that in 12 years using primarily solar
and wind power ambitious well that's one
way to describe it more destructive than
a major war on US soil would be another
way to describe it senator Kirsten
Gillibrand calls the prospect of all of
this quote a really exciting thing Kamel
harris agrees Bernie Sanders isn't
simply a fan he says eliminating fossil
fuels immediately is a moral imperative
that it is absolutely imperative and a
life-and-death issue that we have got to
transform our energy system away from
fossil fuel to sustainable energy what's
so interesting about that is that the
party of science somehow forgot to
consult actual scientists about their
plan talk to someone who studies energy
and see for yourself we are nowhere near
being able to do any of this wind power
is a scam it's an elaborate ripoff
perpetuated on impoverished rural
America by a few heavily subsidized
corporations that are getting rich from
making the landscape uglier Solar is a
promising technology actually but we're
still far from being able to efficiently
store the energy it produces and storage
is key in a power grid Solar is not a
replacement for fossil fuels now or
anytime soon anyone who tells you
otherwise hasn't bothered to learn
anything about it that would describe
most of the people pushing the green New
Deal how well is wind power are gonna
heat your house when there's 30 below
what is the range exactly on those new
solar passenger jets well they don't
know and they don't care because none of
it applies to them it never does